[Music]
so just so we're kind of clear what
we're I'm speaking from on on this topic
I am a molecular biologist by training
so that that is you know my brain does
think a lot as a scientist but I also
have a pretty strong sort of spiritual
practice to my life and a lot of it
centers around nature I feel deep
relationship and kinship with nature and
so a lot of my work is also really
inspired by that relationship and
thinking about ways that we can
integrate perhaps really responsible
just technology use in a way to create a
more brighter future for for ourselves
and all the other species and non-human
beings that we share this planet with
and so that's where I'm coming from and
really what I hope today is to to share
with you and and educate you all on how
this technology works educate you on
sort of where we stand now with making
decisions about whether or if we should
use this technology or how and really
try and present to you some things that
I think are really important anchors for
conversations about this technology and
so to kind of step back a little to not
only I'm a huge you know lover of nature
my my real my real special place of
nature is with trees I feel really deep
connection with trees and I've suffered
quite a lot of grief and watching what's
been happening to our planet
particularly to many of those tree
species that share our planet with us in
the u.s. we have situations where we
have lodgepole pine that are being being
killed off by pine beet boring pine
beetles we have a situation where we
have hemlocks that are dying at
incredibly high rates Beach or under
threat from rust rust and different
Beach bark diseases and another one of
my favorite trees under threat is the
ash and I know that in this country you
also are losing your ash at really fast
rates ash dieback is killing killing ash
trees in this country it's predicted
that over 95% of ash may may perish to
this disease in the US and part
Canada we have this beautiful beetle
called the emerald ash borer which has
to come over from Asia and it's killing
all our ash hundreds and millions of ash
trees have died in North America already
it is predicted that there may be very
few ash trees left by the end of my
lifetime they die within two to three
years of infection this breaks my heart
and and I feel really passionate about
thinking ways that we can try and save
some of this huge immense loss of life
one molecule could be part of that
solution and that's CRISPR CRISPR allows
for what's called gene editing and gene
editing is this new version of genetic
engineering
that's quite inexpensive easy to use and
very specific in how it works so up
until now most genetic engineering
techniques have resulted for example in
huge swathes of DNA being changed in the
process of making a genetic change
CRISPR has been alike into like genetic
scissors and that you can go into the
DNA of literally any little living thing
and change it to the very single base
pair of the code of DNA that this is
pretty this is significant this is big
and we're seeing CRISPR emerge in all
sorts of places whether it's to health
care whether it's industry agriculture
and we're also seeing it starting to
emerge in places where generally genetic
engineering would have been cross
prohibitive or too difficult places like
Public Health and Environmental
Conservation and the way that it works
because I think this is important just I
need to I'm gonna give you a quick
science lesson so we can all be on the
same page and then you can go to your
next dinner party and just really blow
everyone's mind
but basically CRISPR is so easy to use
because it really only requires two
components one is this little blue guy
which is called the guide RNA so the
guide RNA is going to be a specific
sequence that can recognize whatever
sequence of the DNA that you're trying
to change so if that sequence of the DNA
perhaps has the single base change that
causes sickle cell disease you would
create the sequence that recognizes that
to go to that mutation and want to
change it and so the guide RNA localizes
the place of DNA that you want to change
and this which looks much different in
real life under microscopes is an enzyme
called cast 9 and what this does is it
cuts DNA this is an absolute nightmare
for any cell when its DNA is cut it
wants to repair it immediately and so
what you can do is you can kind of use
SERP that DNA repair process by
introducing a DNA template of whatever
you want to introduce into this genetic
sequence it could be changing the
sequence it could be adding an entirely
new sequence it could be you're moving
sequence from the DNA and by doing that
the DNA gets repaired introduces the
change in guala
you have an edited gene obviously it's a
little bit more complicated than this
but this is sort of really how it works
and this is what's this is what's become
so revolutionary in the genetic
engineering space as I mentioned the
ease of use of this has allowed it to be
entering into totally new ways of
solution making or things that we
previously would have been thinking it
couldn't be effective for agriculture is
one I think we can all kind of jump to
the quick conclusion of what this is
looking at this is thinking about using
this for genetically engineered crops
thinking about using this to remove
certain pests environmental conservation
is another so for example people are
discussing could we use CRISPR gene
editing to give coral different kinds of
genetic sequences that make them
resilient to warming sea temperatures
could we use CRISPR gene editing to
suppress the emerald ash borer by
introducing sterility into that
population in North America and saving
the ash tree can we used CRISPR gene
editing to remove invasive species like
the mosquitos in Hawaii that are caught
that are spreading avian malaria to
threaten bird species or there our
friend here the cane toad that is
created causing quite a lot of
instruction in Australia the other
places this being explored is within the
public health space so there's
discussions around can we use CRISPR
gene editing to suppress the malaria
species the malaria carrying species of
mosquito potentially saving 500,000
lives every year ideas around using it
to remove species of mosquitoes that
carry dengue fever Zika fever
chikungunya so this is some big these
are really big ideas and it's and it's
not it's not fully theoretical anymore I
think that's important that we all
understand sir
status of where this is some of this is
still kind of at the very early stages
the choral projects for example are
still very kind of in the idea stage and
proof of concept is it even possible but
we already have for example mosquitoes
that have been genetically engineered
using ways that predate CRISPR by a
company called oxy Tech which has been
releasing these mosquitoes in Brazil the
caiman diamonds Panama parts of
Southeast Asia to try and suppress that
population of mosquitoes and suppress
and then hopefully suppress dengue
transmission there's been an American
chestnut tree that has been genetically
engineered in the u.s. American
chestnuts went functionally extinct in
the u.s. about around the turn of the
19th century and so there's been ideas
about creating these genetically
engineered trees that would be resilient
to an invasive blight that killed them
all off and these are already in
regulatory approval process trying to
release them to be able to reproduce and
spread in the wild and re and re regrow
justness forests and the one that I want
everyone also be aware of is this
project that's funded by the Gates
Foundation this is initiative called
target malaria and they are using CRISPR
gene editing to create a line of
mosquitoes that when released into the
wild which were suppressed the mosquito
population that carries malaria and
hoping to save human life and they do
this because not only does CRISPR will
allow you to make really easy gene edits
in any living thing it's also allowed
for the production of what's called a
CRISPR based gene Drive because if you
think about it if anyone remembers their
natural bio their biology training from
way back when things work through
natural selection right so if you're
gonna release a mosquito that has some
gene on it that you want to push through
a species population it's gonna go mate
with a wild mosquito there's gonna be
only 50% of heritance of those genes and
eventually through natural selection is
quite likely that mosquito would get
pushed out of the population and you
wouldn't really change anything what a
GE Drive does is this gene dry mosquito
not only expresses the gene edit that
you want so say it's to push sterility
through this mosquito population to
suppress the population it also
expresses all the tools the CRISPR so
the cast 9 the gardener I died on a the
stuff that we talked about in that
previous slide so that it makes those
very same edits
in the wild gene that it inherits from
from its wild parent so this gene drive
mosquito is gonna mate with the wild
wild parent the child inherits the gene
edited gene from the gene drive parents
as well as the CRISPR to then edit the
same gene in the wild parent and through
that you get a hundred percent of
inheritance of a gene and over time
every single mosquito in a population
will have that gene edit that you
require and this is the game changer
this is what's both exciting because it
means you can transform populations of
species if you're trying to try and
create a solution for something it's
also what's incredibly frightening you
can completely alter innate and natural
wild species by releasing just a few of
these gene drive mosquitoes and I want
you to hold those try and hold those two
ideas at once because we're really early
in the conversation and just so you know
I sit in the middle to where I both this
is exciting and also scares the crap out
of me and so I think that's where we're
gonna try and stay so we can really
continue this this conversation because
a lot can go wrong okay so yes there's
amazing possible benefits we could save
the coral reefs possibly we could save
you know hundreds and thousands of human
lives every year I mean there's a lot
there's a lot here that could be really
wonderful if it works as we expect and
it's designed responsibly right there's
a lot that could go really badly to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas